inside the very large eyes of a squid
are spherical lenses usually spherical
lenses can't bend the light that passes
through them enough for the image to
look focused but these cephalopods found
a way around that their lenses are built
up of proteins called
s crystallins two loops on the surface
of this protein allow it to self
associate into a gel slight variations
in the protein changes the loops and how
they link the types of links vary in a
gradient along the lens tensor in the
middle and sparser at the edges this
gradient arises during development at
the larval stage the proteins are packed
together in bundles of six forming the
dense gel core when particles can no
longer diffuse easily through the core
the proteins form a layer with fewer
linked as crisp lines on the outside of
the core this continues until the
outermost layer may be with just pairs
of proteins which completes the lens
this change in density across the lens
allows light that passes through the
center of the lens to bend differently
than light that falls on the edge thus
focusing what would have been a query
image the S crystal engine squid lenses
act like patchy colloids these are
groups of molecules that exert
attractive forces on one another and
conform complex shapes out of repeating
units just like the bunches of s
crystalline proteins with these findings
and further research scientists think
squid lenses could eventually be
replicated with simpler materials and
used in optical instruments and Clinics
[Music]
you